e
on
rien
pas content
il est
déjà
l'appui en ce moment je tourne une
comédie musicale avec coranique pierre
koralnik et la musique et de serge
gainsbourg et il se fit très contente
parce que ça me plaît beaucoup mais
c'est la route bourg le rôle le plus
difficile pour porter le poids d'une
comédie musicale vous avez choisi ana
pourquoi est-ce que c'est l'oiseau rare
wii wii fit d'abord c'est un oiseau rare
d'avant sur le plan enfin c'est
vachement que c'est une artiste ce qui
est pas tellement courant c'est plus
c'est pas si c'est une comédienne ne
s'est pas sujet qui me préoccupe
beaucoup j'ai rien contre les comédiens
enfin je crois que c'est très important
d'abord une artiste ensuite c'est un
être humain c'est pur instinct mordre et
galvaudé le sait mais c'est un être
humain et c'est une très jolie fille et
en plus ça c'est quelqu'un qui a une
conscience professionnelle formidable
qui travaillent énormément elle a
travaillé beaucoup pour apprendre à
chanter pour pour danser la soirée elle
a dansé pendant des heures et maintenant
elle sait tout faire
la télé
hélas
dior je suis
moi
elle chante pas comme tout le monde
anna annonça personnel qu'est ce qu'elle
a de particulier elle a des moyens
vocaux ce qui est très rare et puis
beaucoup de choses quoi spécifiques
quoi changer l'humour c'est très rare au
puy sensualité dans une gamme très
étendue
le moyen ça super mat der fait quelque
chose pour elle n'a jamais fait pour
personne d'autre
je suis très mauvais coucheurs si je
fais deux titres c'est que jamais
accroché